nous n'avons pas
appris énormément de choses que nous ne
sachions déjà nous avons acté un certain
nombre de divergences que nous avons
moins clairement sur
dire les principes de précaution à
mettre en oeuvre on va pas se cacher que
nous avons j'aime en ce qui me concerne
c'est pas le cas de l'ensemble et les
autres représentants mouvement mais j'ai
en ce qui me concerne les divergences
sur
notamment les choix qui ont été faits
mise en quarantaine un certain nombre de
circulation totalement libres d'autres
j'ai jamais caché que je les trouvais en
l'occurrence en l'occurrence incohérent
toute une série d'engagements ont été
pris en terme de préparation d'une
aggravation de l'épidémie donc on en
prend acte et évidemment on se réjouit
que le gouvernement soit sur la brèche
moi j'aurais préféré je les dis
d'ailleurs au premier ministre le centre
interministériel de crise soit mis en
oeuvre il est normalement présidées par
le premier ministre n'est pas encore le
cas je pense que le gouvernement
considère que la situation n'est pas
encore assez
périlleuse pour le mettre en oeuvre mais
je pense que
ça donnerait une cohérence si vous
voulez d'ensemble aux actions qui sont
qui vont être amenés à être menée
puisque l'on voit que la situation de
l'allemagne s'aggrave et que
pourront légitimement penser qu'il
puisse y avoir un profil d'aggravation
en france du même type que celui que
vient aujourd'hui
my ils fabriquent pas seulement ou
d'ailleurs et d'autres pays qui est
aujourd'hui enregistrent des cas qui
sont encore à
un nombre minimum confirmer comme invité
non merci gérant il met en dessous du
truc qui va s'envoler qui va me tomber
dessus
il est gentil mais et voyez je vous avez
noté que je suis attentive aux principes
de prix patience
excusez moi je crois qu'on s'est mal
compris ou c'est moi qui ai peut-être me
suis mal exprimé
je parle exprimant expressément de
l'iran et j'ai d'ailleurs fait un tweet
sur ce sujet en nous dans tous les pays
limitrophes de l'iran ou pris des
mesures n'ont pas oublié dans le monde
de fermeture totale mais de restrictions
surveillance de la frontière oui je le
conteste oui oui je le dis clairement
enfin écoutez si on me demande mon avis
je les dis je l'exprimé angers le droit
aussi d'être en désaccord avec les choix
qui sont faits j'ai dit que en l'espace
de 24 heures dix pays
je dis bien dix pays ont au moins un cas
alors qu'il n'en avait pas issue qui est
la conséquence de quelqu'un qui serait
allé en voyage ou kate en provenance
d'italie
c'est un fait vous avez comme j'aime
beaucoup les italiens donc c'est pas un
problème de société à leur égard bien
sûr mais c'est un fait
gpi dix pays ont été ou aujourd'hui un
cas qui est un cas qui a un lien avec
les i je pense que il est dans le cadre
du principe de précaution utile d'en
tenir compte et encore une fois il
existe des incohérences vous les avez
noté et je les ai noté c'est vrai que
l'on ne comprend pas pourquoi les
enfants qui reviennent d'italie où leur
demande de faire une sorte d'auto
quarantaine qui est un concept assez
nouveau mais bon pourquoi pas et que
dans le même temps on laisse 3000
italien venir un match de football à
lyon
c'est incohérent cela ils se sont un peu
multiplié air france a suspendu ses vols
dès le début de l'épidémie
en chine mais les compagnies aériennes
chinoises continuer à atterrir en france
ben moi j'ai pas eu de réponse
particulièrement précises sur ces
incohérences là mais maintenant je
prends acte que le gouvernement gouverne
après tout
et c'est bien légitime je prends acte
aussi des divergences d'analystes que je
peux avoir avec lui sur un certain
nombre dans un certain nombre de
domaines dont ils seraient confinés
comme en italie pourquoi en confident
italie et pas en france
non parce que la situation est
aujourd'hui tout à fait différente en
italie et en france la situation en
italie et la situation d'une épidémie
qu'on appelle hors contrôle
ça n'est pas c'est une formulation
juridique l'épidémie hors contrôle c'est
une épidémie sur lequel on n'a pas de
médicaments bon ben ça c'est à tout le
monde mais avec un nombre exponentiel de
vous dire deux cas ça n'est pas encore
le cas en france du mercy et
par conséquent
il n'y a pas de situation de confinement
même si en réalité on en a déjà fait il
me semble et 6 ce qui s'est passé dans
la station de ski était en fait un
confinement
il ya un certain michael qui ont été
fermés donc bon je jure les confinements
s'éteint c'est un principe qui est
utilisé assez régulièrement
avez vous des inquiétudes sur le
déroulement de l'élection municipale
c'est extrêmement difficile de vous
répondre les gouvernements pour le
convoi pourra pas non plus parce qu'en
réalité le principe c'est que bien sûr
les élections municipales vont avoir
lieu
le principe d'une épidémie est peut-être
pas demain d'une pandémie mondiale c'est
qu'on sait absolument pas comment elle
évolue
voilà mais je crois que le gouvernement
nous a rassurés pour mettre le premier
ministre nous a rassurés en nous
indiquant que
après oui au moment où c'est par les
élections municipales
et demander la fermeture des frontières
le pen est ce que c'est par faire un peu
de la politique politicienne à un moment
oui mais on peut aussi supprimer
l'opposition considérer qu'elle n'a rien
à dire est qu'elle n'a pas d'idée que
s'il en a il faut pas qu'elles les
expriment mois encore une fois j'ai été
très clair depuis à moi ce que je me
suis intéressé dès le départ à 7 à 7
épidémie j'ai même je crois été la
première à demander il n'y a plus un
près d'un mois
est-ce que l'on suspende les vols en
provenance de chine ont veillé que j'ai
une belle cohérence je pense que ce
n'est pas peut-être suffisant la
maîtrise des frontières mais que c'était
évidemment un des éléments pour limiter
la propagation
et encore une fois je vous en donne une
preuve c'est que je le répète dix pays
dans les 48 dernières heures dix pays
dans le monde ont développé au moins un
cas qui est lié au foyer infectieux
italien voilà donc je pense oui que
cette idéologie que je ressens à droite
comme à gauche d'ailleurs qui consiste à
dire en aucun cas en aucun cas jamais
jamais il ne faut pouvoir envisager la
moindre maîtrise d'une frontière
m'apparaît relevé plus de l'idéologique
du pragmatisme qui est nécessaire pour
faire face à ce type de crises et puis
résiste même disent que c'est compliqué
b compliqué bien sûr compliqué bien sûr
pas suffisant en soi même bien sûr mais
c'est un des éléments qui permet tout de
même d'éviter la contamination
quand une fois beaucoup de pays ont pris
ces décisions tous les pays autour de
l'iran ont pris ces décisions
la russie qui est pourtant un ami
diplomatique de la chine a pris des
décisions il ya plus de 15 jours
maintenant de fermeture totale de sa
frontière avec la chine
nous verrons si un certain nombre de
pays ont réussi plus facilement que
d'autres à empêcher ce type 2
comment dire le développement on a des
épidémies